let's talk a little bit about dna
cloning which is all about making
identical copies of a piece of dna and
usually it's a piece of dna that that
codes for something we care about it is
a gene that will express itself as a
protein that we think is useful in in
some way
now you might have also heard the term
cloning in terms of the clone wars in
star wars or dolly the sheep and that is
a related idea if you're cloning an
animal or an organism like a sheep well
then you are creating an animal that has
the exact genetic material as the
original animal but when we talk about
cloning and dna cloning we're talking
about something a little bit a little
bit simpler although as we'll see it's
still quite fascinating it's identical
copies of a piece of dna
so how do we do that
well let's say that this is a strand of
dna right over here and i'm just drawing
it as a line but this is a double
stranded and i'll just write it down
this is double stranded
i don't want to have to take the trouble
of keep drawing the multiple strands
actually let me just draw let me just
try to draw
the two strands just so we remind
ourselves so there we go this is the
double stranded dna
and
let's say that
this part of this dna has a gene that we
want to clone
we want to make copies of this right
over here so gene to clone
gene
to clone well the first thing we want to
do is we want to cut this gene out
somehow and the way we do that is using
restriction enzymes and there's a bunch
of different restriction enzymes and i
personally find it fascinating that we
as a civilization have gotten to the
point that we can find and identify
these enzymes and we know at what points
of of dna that they can cut they
recognize specific sequences and then we
can figure out well what which
restriction enzyme should we use to cut
out different pieces of dna but we have
gotten to that point as a civilization
so we use restriction enzymes we might
use one restriction enzyme let me use a
different color here
that that
latches on right over here and
identifies the genetic sequence right
over here and cuts
right in the right place
so that might be a restriction enzyme
right over there and then you might use
another restriction enzyme that
identifies with the sequence at the
other side that we want to cut
so let me label these
these
those things right over there those are
restriction enzymes
restriction enzymes
and so now you would have after you
apply the restriction enzymes you will
have
just that gene you might have a little
bit left over on either side but
essentially you have cut out the gene
you've used the restriction enzymes to
cut out your gene and then what you want
to do is you want to paste it into what
we'll call a plasmid and a plasmid is is
a is a piece of genetic material
that sits outside of chromosomes but
that can reproduce along or that could i
guess we could say can replicate along
with the machinery of the or the genetic
machinery of the organism or it can even
express itself just like the the genes
of the organism that are in the
chromosomes express themselves so then
so this is where we cut let me write
this we cut
we cut out the gene and then we want to
paste it
then we want to paste it
into a plasmid and plasmids tend to be
circular dna
so we will paste it into a plasmid and
in order for them to fit the there's
oftentimes
these overhangs over here so you might
have an overhang over there you might
have an overhang over there
and so the the plasmid that we're
placing in might have complementary base
pairs over the overhangs which will
allow it easier it will become easier
for them to react with each other
if they have these overhangs
so let me we're pasting it into the
plasmid
and this is amazing because obviously
gna this isn't stuff that we can like
you know manipulate with our hands the
way that we would uh copy and paste
things with tape you're you're making
these solutions and you're applying the
restriction enzymes the restriction
enzymes are just in in mass cutting
these things they're bumping in just the
right way to cause this reaction to
happen then you're taking those genes
and then you're putting them with the
plasmids that happen to have the right
sequences at their ends so that they
match up and then you also put in a
bunch of dna ligase
dna ligase
to
to connect the backbones right over here
and we also saw dna ligase when we
studied replication so that is dna
ligase which you can think of it is
helping to do helping to do the pasting
and so now we have this plasmid and we
want to insert it into an organism that
can make the copies for us and an
organism that's typically used is or a
type of organism is bacteria and e coli
in particular and so what we could do is
we could
let's say that we have a bunch of let's
say you have a vial right over here
you have a vial
and it has a solution in it with a bunch
of e coli
a bunch of e coli and you actually
wouldn't be able to see it visually but
there's e coli in that in that solution
and then you would put your plasmids
which you would be even harder to see in
that solution and somehow we want the e
coli that we want the bacteria to take
up the plasmid and the technique that's
typically done is is giving some type of
a shock to the system that makes the
bacteria take up the plasmids and the
typical shock is a heat shock and this
isn't fully understood how the heat shot
how the heat shock works but it does and
so people have been using this for some
time
so if you have a bacteria
you have a bacteria right over here
it has
it has its existing dna
so this is its existing
genetic
material right over there let me label
this
this is
the bacteria
you put it in the presence of our
plasmids
so you put it in the presence of our
plasmid and you apply the heat shock and
some of that bacteria is going to take
in the plasmid
it's going to take in the plasmid
and so just like that
it's going to take it
it's going to take it in
and so what you then do
is you place the solution that has your
bacteria some of which will have taken
up the plasmid and you put it and then
you try to grow the bacteria on a plate
so let me draw that so let me draw
so here we have
a
a plate to grow our bacteria on
and it has
it has nutrients right over here that
bacteria can grow on
it has nutrients
it has nutrients and so you could say
okay we'll put this here and then a
bunch of bacteria will just grow
so you would see things like this which
would be many many many many cells of
bacteria there would be colonies of
bacteria you could just let them grow
but there's a problem here because i
mentioned some of the bacteria will take
up the plasmids and some won't and so
you won't know hey you know when when
this this bacteria when it keeps
replicating it might form one of these
it might form one of these colonies so
this is a colony that you like
so this one is a good colony i'll put a
check mark there but maybe this colony
is formed by a initial bacteria or a set
of bacteria that did not take up the
plasmid so it won't contain the actual
gene in question so you don't want that
one so how do you select for
the bacteria that actually took up the
plasmid
well what you do is
besides the gene that you care about
that you want to make copies of you also
place a
a
gene
for
antibiotic resistance in your plasmid
so now you have a gene for antibiotic
resistance here and so only the the
bacteria i think it's amazing that we as
humanity have are able to do these types
of things but now only the bacteria that
have taken up the plasmid will have that
antibiotic resistance and so what you do
is in your nutrients you move nutrients
plus antibiotics plus an antibiotic
antibiotic and so this one will survive
because it has that resistance it has
that gene that allows it to
not be susceptible to the antibiotics
but these are not going to survive
they're not even going to happen they're
not even going to grow because there's
antibiotics mixed in with those
nutrients and so this is a pretty cool
thing you started with the gene that you
cared about you cut and pasted it into
into our plasmid let me write the labels
down
into our plasmid
that also contained a gene that that can
that gave antibiotic resistance to any
bacteria that takes up the plasmid you
put these plasmids in the presence of
the bacteria you provide some type of a
shock maybe a heat shock so that some of
the bacteria takes it up and then the
bacteria starts reproducing and as it
reproduces it also is reproducing the
plasmids and because it has this
antibiotic resistance it is going to
grow on this nutrient antibiotic mixture
and the other bacteria that did not take
up the plasmids are not going to grow
and so just like that you can take this
you can take this colony right over here
and put it into another solution or
continue to grow it and you will have
multiple copies of that gene that are
inside of that bacteria
now the next question and i'm over
simplifying things for fairly
dramatically is well how do you you now
have a bunch of bacteria that have a
bunch of copies of that gene how do you
make use of it
well the bacteria themselves let's say
that gene is for something you want to
manufacture
say insulin for diabetics well you could
actually use that bacteria's machinery
we use it's it's it's reproductive
machinery to keep replicating the
genetic information but you can also use
it's it's it's productive machinery i
guess you could say
it's going to express its existing dna
but it can also express the genes that
are on the plasmid in fact that's what
gives its and that's what would give the
bacteria its antibiotic resistance but
it could if this gene was safe for
insulin well then the bacteria will
produce will produce a bunch of insulin
a bunch of insulin molecules which you
might be able to use in some way and i'm
not going to go into all the details of
how you will get the insulin out and how
you can make use of it but needless to
say it's pretty cool that we could even
get to this point